Tony and Lou chaotic output boys you to
tango and today we're gonna watch me see
how fast I go go
[Music]
well I'm sitting here at outside working
on one of my latest projects here and my
little boy puts on his bicycle helmet
and gets his little push bike out and
says daddy I want to I want to film me
doing going down the driveway so this is
one of those times you just need to put
it down go play with your kid a little
bit so we are going to film
Tommy's epic alright Tommy oh I have to
go up with you I was gonna videotape you
oh I'll see if I can follow you okay go
for it
that's a ESIC try that was an epic try
okay what do again you see I could go
around yeah is so fast
[Music]
have you okay well let me take a look a
bottom okay let's okay what was the huge
crack in your bottom get it there's a
big crack of your bottom throw it in a
trash can
mom's worried he just crashed a little
bit just hit his bulb on the ground all
right tell me won't you talk to the
camera I want to tell us what happened I
like to fair I went too high and not and
balance to have fast oh so when you go
too fast to get there yourself yeah yeah
that's what happens
looks like he almost hit the back of the
car too no he didn't oh no it's right
we're selling the car Hurley
tried to do that today you accidentally
hit the car okay so what'd you learn
about last time what went wrong oh okay
so you're gonna go a little slower this
time you'd go a little fast all right
we'll see what happens all right tom
that was pretty epic Taavi
all right tell me we got some good
footage here we got you going very fast
we've got a nice crash now we need to
make the thumbnail and we get to do some
clickbait you wanna do some clickbait
yes all right let's do some clickbait
hold on a second all right all right I
don't know if there's anything we
couldn't find in my garage if we dig
deeply deep enough but yes I have a
quart of stage blood oh yeah how's that
how's that that looks pretty good tub
you look at the camera see now we got to
do our clickbait so here why don't you
lay on the ground right here and act
like you crashed and died okay I'm gonna
put your bike on you like you crashed
with your bike oh no Tommy's dead okay
now we got to take a picture okay
hold really still okay let's go to the
bathroom so you can see your face
[Music]
daddy stop it okay okay okay all right
thanks for watching out you like to stay
up painful don't forget to click
Subscribe melded bleeding